we have hatred mail for you this week
quick reminder if you're not familiar
with what hatred mail is this is
everything you need to know about it
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom alright so we've got our bingo
card list of common themes in hatred
mail misspelling you apostrophe re as
why oh you are is a common one it
generally horrible grammar is another
one homophobic sentiments directed to me
or to Pat is a common one cut is a
common one and also on that list is
anti-semitism and that's the one we're
going back to for this week's hatred
mail Pakman is why people hate the left
david is apparently a lying cuts whose
service should be boycotted how about
this validate ts1
david pakman is a Jew to david pakman is
dishonest
ergo some jews are dishonest and over
the Jew gold david hey you know what
this is the first time a hatred has ever
used the latin for their for her go yeah
from the traditional teaching of sort of
logic and i don't know what that means i
guess it means even people who know a
single latin word can be horribly
anti-semitic and also this is actually a
valid argument although unfortunately
it's not a sound because you're not
dishonest yes i think you would benefit
greatly from the upcoming david pakman
show critical thinking miniseries that's
exactly right i think i think that he
would and by the way when i say that you
can't talk sense into these people so
work at work on just getting the vote
out this is sort of a perfect example of
that and i will also remind you that you
can turn hatred mail into something
positive you can give a middle finger to
the hey tree 'it's by using the
membership discount code hey tree at
forty if you go to david pakman.com
slash membership you pick any membership
you like and when you get to check out
time
to the checkout phase of the process you
use the coupon code hey treat for tha TR
IOT 4-0 and it will save you 40% which
is an absolutely lovely and wonderful
thing if there was such a thing as this
Jew gold that he's talking about would
you share it with him
absolutely not are you crazy no why
would I why would I share Jew gold with
hatred that's insane